dude how great is this were grown men
left our wives and kids to just the
stupid questions how great is our life
hey babe yeah I'm still at work yeah we
just yeah we're a bit up
yeah Daily Show hey Trevor what's that
would you a big trip Trevor Noah need me
I'll be home about 30 let me get one
more yeah yeah welcome back to stupid
questions I'm here with Roy Wood jr. how
you doing I'm good laughing you feel go
we both got the open jacket so it's
stupid shirts on couple the dads trying
to look single a couple of dads trying
not to show our kids
all right we're both dads so what's the
stupidest thing your kid has ever done
he took some pasta okay and shoved
inside my playstation 4 truffle oil
bowtie pasta the PlayStation on the side
has the exhaust and holes and he's
shoving pasta inside the exhaust fans
two days later I go to play playstation
whole house smell like pasta I gotta
give him one them laurence fishburne
keep on eating boys in the hood tray
here's a stupid question how many
pretzels you think you've eaten so far I
[Music]
[Applause]
don't know they're sprayed some on
them before I hope it was water you
could fight any animal what animal would
you fight wolf wolf why because if you
take out the alpha wolf the rest of the
pack of wolves have to respect you as
the new alpha now I have a pack of
wolves with me that's some good
you're not a badass I would be if I was
just rolling down the street and it's 12
wolves just following me they go who was
that dude and Louis alpha wolf bitch
yes you're the new alpha it's like I'm
jail will you shank the biggest dude
absolutely run the jail so that's what I
would do Matt do you have a boat no I
don't have a boat I don't know I'm just
you know people assuming you know thats
a good call
well if you had a boat what would you
name it beaches be trippin beaches be
trippin
that's your new t-shirt yeah bitches be
trippin this is a picture my boat right
off the edge of a beach cuz my boat
don't like beaches I don't even like the
water though I saw a video of Beyonce
and jay-z she's riding a jet ski and a
swimming pool that's Bo that's Paul I
have pointless but it's baller but I
feel like just in regular life to have
an ocean vehicle which is happening in
the back I'm a but nobody else can go on
the pool then right can you go in the
pool if I had a house and I had a fool I
won't let nobody on my pool really so if
you got a house in a pool I can't come
over the pool walk around a bitch but
you alright so I got you your stupid
gift you ready okay it's dumb it's still
okay so you're from Alabama I want to
give you two things that the state of
Alabama doesn't have and that's a hockey
puck they'll have a hockey team and
teeth so I just thought hockey and teeth
you know that's a little bit kind of
like just a fun razz but I see you got
upset about it do you have good teeth
boy what do you think of the gift huh
know that a plate there you go Alabama
all right that was stupid questions with
Chris de Stefano that was Roy Wood jr.
we appreciate you guys watching we're
here every Friday night don't forget
we're two grown men in our 30s and this
is what we're doing I went to college
[Music]